last week we reported to you that a
speaker of the house Nancy Pelosi would
be stepping down from leadership of the
democratic party Democrats of course
poised to become the minority Party in
the House of Representatives based on
the November 8th election results in the
2022 midterms Nancy Pelosi stepping down
but will stay in congress and Democrats
have now decided that it is Hakeem
Jeffries a former guest of this program
who will become minority leader for
Democrats in the House of
Representatives the New York Times
reporting in a show of Unity House
Democrats elect Hakeem Jeffries minority
leader a new Trio including
Representatives Catherine Clark of
Massachusetts as number two and Pete
Aguilar of California as number three
will take the reins in January replacing
speaker Nancy Pelosi and her team
um Jeffries is 52 years old Clark is 59
and Aguilar is 43
certainly moving in the direction of
younger which is something that many
Democrats have been calling for now it
shouldn't surprise anyone if you've been
following American politics for any
period of time
to know that the right is immediately
Framing and attacking Hakeem Jeffries as
some kind of extreme radical of course
the reality is that he is nothing of the
sort and I would encourage you if you
really just want to see the way that he
presents himself and talks about issues
and thinks through issues check out my
interview with Hakeem Jeffries from some
years ago the topics will be less
relevant to 2022 but it is of course
still the same Hakeem Jeffries here is
Newsmax with a commentary on Hakeem
Jeffries they're saying much of the
decision was motivated simply by race
and the fact that Hakeem Jeffries is not
white and they say a lot of the exact
things that we would expect but it's
important to remember they would be
saying this no matter who was chosen
all right other news tonight uh
Democrats picked to replace Nancy Pelosi
indicates that their party has no
intention of veering away from the
squad's favorite brand of politics
Hakeem Jeffries
is an anti-us oil rabid defender of the
pro-abortion death cult he's an election
denier
he's a pretty radical New York
congressman
he tweeted numerous times following the
2016 election at one point writing the
more we learn about the 2016 election
the more illegitimate it becomes now you
need to understand they love to play
this game so first of all some of the
things that that this Newsmax host says
well he's part of the pro-abort pro-pro
death machine abortion whatever
he like most Americans supports abortion
rights that's not super controversial
but everything has to be framed it's
completely outrageous on Newsmax when
you are perpetuating this brand of fear
and outrage politics that has completely
supplanted policy for the American right
wing this issue of election denier you
know when people on the left questioned
the legitimacy of Trump's presidency
they were not literally saying it was
stolen in the way that Trump has said
about 2020 there were sort of two
meanings to Trump as illegitimate as
president one meaning was that Trump
Rose to the presidency on the shoulders
of foreign support from Russia and of
course that's been demonstrated now of
course it has not been demonstrated that
Trump and Putin got together and ate
Frog's legs while plotting exactly how
Putin would do it but we know
Russia had a preference for Trump over
Hillary and used social media and other
influence Avenues to try to make it so
that Trump would win and not Hillary
Clinton it's not do the election over
its people were swayed by Propaganda
that came from a foreign adversary okay
very very different and then number two
uh Trump was illegitimate in the
colloquial sense in that he had no
business being president of the United
States had no idea what was going on
didn't know up from down was completely
clueless it is not fair to say that
those are election deniers in the way
that people are going around like
Marjorie Taylor green literally saying
oh more people actually tried to vote
for Trump but Joe Biden manipulated the
machines or whatever the case may be not
even remotely comparable and it's
important to understand that when they
pull that line out let's listen to a
little bit more of this and now this man
leads leads the house Democrats so you
see the road that that party is going
down Republican strategist Aaron perini
joins me now to talk about this good to
see you Aaron it's a pretty radical
Choice I'm not surprised because you
knew it wasn't going to be a white guy I
think we all knew that but it's a very
extreme choice
it's an extreme choice and Democrats
like to use this adage right show me
your budget and I'll show you your
values well show me your leader and I'll
show you your party they have picked an
election denier you know the green New
Deal loving champion of Russian
disinformation Hakeem Jeffries to leave
and of course that's completely
inaccurate and there is really nothing
at all radical about Hakeem Jeffries I
think that Jeffries does have a very
difficult position and timing he is
entering leadership of the democratic
party as Democrats have lost control of
the house number one and number two as
Republicans are particularly
incentivized to make the next two years
about you know Hunter Biden and maybe
even Hillary Clinton's emails if you can
imagine so a difficult time to become
part of Democratic Leadership but an
interesting choice brilliant guy check
out his interview with me some years ago